[Music]
[Music]
you only get one life what will you do
in the next week to start making it
worth living smile more then I would say
it's mine you had a beautiful someone
loved you
nice as I'm sweets on roof if you have
two feet and a heart each you're blessed
- I mean it's it's a nice it's a nice
thought in terms of just you know if you
can if you're alive
who then been here you're doing better
than a lot what a beautiful day to be
alive where else would I be if I wanted
to feel alive very nice
probably in heaven we are enjoying
beautiful San Diego with our good
friends today when did you last get in
touch with your best friends with love
from Germany
yesterday yesterday yesterday talked to
my best friends I'm a 21 year old girl
in San Diego on vacation with my
boyfriend if you could disappear
anywhere with anyone where would you go
and who would you bring so spread love I
would probably go
with my husband
I have some lovely Caribbean island
drink margaritas on the beach I'm a 36
year old mother of two toddlers from the
East Coast time is always an issue
what's holding you back from the life
you want to it nothing I am living the
life I want to live I am a 20 year old
man who recently got married and life is
getting better day by day don't
overthink life live it and enjoy well
for this person he's blessed and he's
happy he's living in joy and my
blessings go out to him and his new
marriage I am free from captivity and
enjoying life to the fullest the Lord
broke my chains and he can't break yours
something is it was deep every day is a
good day it's up to you to make it great
that's a good rope I like it stay
positive every pot has its lid is there
someone who fits the lid to your pot
interesting would you mind answering
that as well
there's no led to my pot not yet anyway
[Music]
do you see the same colors I see
possibly unless you're colorblind do you
notice your surroundings as you walk
sometimes sin depends on if I'm on my
phone or you know just depends on what
I'm doing or where I am or who I'm what
majority of the time yes I'm Gerry
dependent majority of the time no you
listen to all the sounds around you as
you walk yes kind of I mean I guess I'm
alone yeah what's your favorite
childhood memory have you ever been out
of the United States yeah I'm from
Argentina I think my first rising bike
was so cool I got a lot of precious
[Music]
scratches yeah I do because it was the
first time I feel like grown up what's
your favorite place in the world
I like Croatia what is really pretty and
relaxed and
a great vacation spot who is your best
friend and wife
yeah Oh Carissa because she is what I
define as my soulmate we are very
similar and yeah I guess that that
answers the question you said what I
define as my soulmate so how would you
define that I guess just somebody that
you can connect with on a deeper level
on an emotional level and somebody that
just understands you without even having
to say a word attention of opposites we
learn from what hurts us just as much as
we just as much as what loves us I think
it's very true and um also kind of sweet
you have enough you doing up and you are
enough that's really nice yeah I wasn't
expecting something so nice
[Music]
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]